the rejection of everything that  everyone has ever said or done or  believed simply because we weren't  around when they said or did or believed  it an unshakable confidence in our own  rightness and perfection and similarly  an unshakable confidence in the idiocy  and wickedness of everyone who came  before us it is an expression of  narcissism now you might think that this  hatred of the past that's taken over our  culture in recent years stems from some  supreme confidence  in the future i don't think so this idea  that we are dismissive of what came  before us because we are so excited  about what is to come it doesn't it  doesn't reflect that our society  actually has rather low expectations for  the future poll after poll shows that  americans increasingly are fearful about  the future and this trend is  particularly pronounced among young  americans